request that you give us your customary
extra time and even a little bit extra
if you can afford it uh in order that we
can cover all the topics and i'm very
grateful for that
i will do my best to oblige you as a
service about it i've got
um and um prime minister
you your slightly
horse of voice
this afternoon you can save your voice
by giving nice short answers
and i will give the committee um
not if you keep me for longer short
shift if they if their questions are too
long though they are entitled to use
their time as they please
um so we'll go straight to the first
topic um william bragg chairman of
packer
thank you savannah good afternoon
prime minister
prime minister can you understand the
public moves that there is
in much of the country about standards
issues around members of parliament and
ministers and and care to reflect upon
that in light of the uh events a couple
of weeks ago
uh yes thank you um william thank you mr
mr rang i think that
there is
a
feeling that we need to be
getting on and
ensuring that we have the utmost uh
propriety in our in our dealings with
each other with the with the public
and that the public can have full
confidence in
uh the system
and
um
what i
would like to place on on record
uh and i've said it before
is that i think it was a a mistake two
weeks ago
uh to to conflate
um the
uh
very sad and difficult case of a
particular colleague who'd fallen foul
of the
commissioner for standards and standards
process
and the
need for
as many
colleagues saw it rightly or wrongly for
reform and improvement to this to the
system and uh to in particular to the
system for
appeals in in the event of very
difficult cases and
what i hoped to achieve was some sort of
cross-party progress on that
uh plainly that it
wasn't possible
what i would like to to see now is
cross-party uh progress on uh endorsing
some of the i think very useful
conclusions of the independent report on
the the report of the independent
committee on standards and privileges of
2018. thank you and just specifically on
the ministerial code um as i'm sure that
the chair the standards committee will
have further questions
but um what how do you view the
ministerial code do you see it as a
constitutional document do you see it as
a guide do you see it as advisory what's
its status in your eyes i think the
ministerial code is extremely important
as you know it's been greatly
strengthened in the last
few years
and
elaborated in in in very clear terms
uh to give guidance for for ministers
what i've
done is is brought in an an independent
advisor to to me is the uh i'm the
upholder the guarantor of the
ministerial code but i what i think i
benefit from is independent advice about
how to
implement it and that's what our lord
guide provides
as well as that oversight us prime
minister are bound by the ministerial
code is that's right of course
do you sense a slight conflict of
interest
in in that in that settlement
and might not the independent advisor
do well to be invested with the powers
of initiation of investigation
well that's a very good good question i
think the
the
there are difficult constitutional
issues raised uh in in that but where we
where we've got to is that a lord guide
has
the
the ability
uh to
uh suggest
uh
to me that something
might
be worth investigating or that there's
some issue that has been raised under
the ministerial code and
i think it's highly unlikely that i
would in any circumstances disagree
uh with him
um
and
we proceed on on that basis and i find
him an exceptionally valuable
source of
advice
and to give an example recently
the committee will have noted that um
the business secretary wrote a letter to
the commissioner for the standards uh
setting out uh an explanation and uh an
apology for some some recent comments
and uh that was certainly uh something
that was generated in the course of
consultation between
me and lord guy and traditionally
breaches of the code have meant
resignation or sacking one or the other
do you think it's therefore too much of
a blunt instrument and because your
update data's on the any progress that's
been made of a graduation of sanctions
that might make uh the ministerial code
uh more applicable yes that's a very
also not important the ministerial code
is is quite uh it's quite compendious it
covers a lot of uh things and uh it's as
it was initially constituted it was
basically a a a hair trigger
code so that uh one toe cap over uh any
of the of the red lines and uh you were
you were you were finished um it's the
view of lord guy and i think that uh
it's reasonable uh that there should be
gradations and that uh a there should be
ways in which
um there should be other sanctions and a
a breach of the uh minister a small
breach i should say the ministerial
coach should not necessarily lead to
resignations that's his that's his view
as i understand it
following the the green sill episode if
we might describe it as that uh you
commissioned nigel boardman
to review what had happened and part two
of that was published
recently admittedly during the middle of
the government reshuffle
have you considered those
recommendations and in particular do you
think that acaba
in its uh in strictures of employment
restrictions and former ministers do you
think those recommendations should be
made legally binding as uh boardman
suggests
uh we'll we're considering uh the
boardman uh recommendations
uh mr rag and we will uh report to back
to you and uh and to your committee but
but in this moment prime minister what's
your what's your thoughts on what i
think the instinctive thoughts i i
certainly think that the the ocoba
process is is invaluable and
it should be incumbent upon anybody
uh leading public office to to follow
those rules pretty toothless
organization though
uh no uh the
uh
people have to abide by uh the okober
rules and
uh the um
the cabinet
office uh uh so the case and now there's
a leading work with uh cobra and uh eric
pickles
improvements can be made and we'll be
reporting that but with respect they
don't have to follow the recommendations
they can do what they like they're
issued of a very polite letter uh but
they can simply disregard that and
there's quite a few examples of that
that has happened
so so it's pretty toothless organization
do you think therefore as part of this
uh work that we're taking forward it can
be strengthened i i we do think that
there is scope for improving it what i'm
saying to you is as a result we haven't
yet uh
formed a hard and fast view about how to
uh how to do that thank you thank you
thank you
on that matter we'll be we'll be
updating
uh
later this year later this year there's
not really as much time there chris this
year chris brown thanks very much and uh
good afternoon prime minister can i just
check in one of the answers there you
just said that the business secretary um
had written to the parliamentary
commissioner for standards apologizing
um excellent as i understand it you were
saying there that lord guy had asked him
to do so
quite what i said i said that uh
the the uh
process by which the letter was
generated was uh one that involved uh
collaboration between uh me and lord
guyt and uh my reliance upon him for his
advice so you tell them the business
secretary to apologize and that's a very
important thing so you told the business
secretary to apologize uh that's a
matter of me and the business secretary
but uh
if you if you mean did lord gait ask the
business secretary to apologize the
answer to that is no
but and but you're not telling us then
whether you did or didn't because some
of us might gently suggest to you that
we were surprised that the business
secretary would freelance when he went
on the air one presumed that you'd asked
him to go on the air to call for the
price for the parliamentary commissioner
for standards to resign yeah well that's
obviously all right no i didn't i didn't
do that and did you know he was going to
do that no and just to just to clear the
the matter up um since you don't leave
any ambiguity for uh for the committee i
certainly thought it was
um
[Music]
appropriate for the business secretary
to write in the way that he did and um
okay supported him in that
um why
is the list of ministerial interests
only published twice a year because most
of every year it's not even an accurate
list of ministers let alone of their
interests
well uh the
list of ministerial interests is is
there to be consulted i think uh it's
in so far as
members also serve as those mps which of
course the ministers awards and speeches
of course they do uh their their
parliamentary interests are there to be
consulted and to be updated a very
regular intro very very very regular
intervals well the commons publishers
are rolling a rolling register which
includes everything every fortnight and
and you can see the whole of the house
of commons on a single document
but the government tucks all the details
for ministers away in 232 separate
documents online
that isn't really transparency is it
well i i i disagree the the
mps who are ministers that's uh
majority of ministers have to register
all their uh their interests in the
parliamentary register
is the additional register of
ministerial interests okay so let me
give you an example if two mps were
sitting next to each other in a box
being wined and dined by um guests of um
some business uh or industry body and
the um one was a backbench mp and the
other was a government minister the
backbench mp would have to register this
with the house of commons within 28 days
but the minister and would have to give
details of the amount that it cost but
the minister wouldn't have to register
the amount of money that it cost at all
ever
and the registration would only appear
six months later
that's just unfair isn't it shouldn't
there be one rule for everybody
well i think that uh you what you get i
i'm sure the most mps would register
their uh
their interest in the if they've been
taken out to uh to dinner though they
would register their interests in the in
the register so you think ministers
should i think that the system uh that
we have is the is the one that uh that i
inherited and it seems to work pretty
well but if you have if you have
recommendations uh mr brown to
to improve it then i'm sure that uh the
house will be interested to to see them
excellent thank you um can i just ask
you because i don't quite understand do
you think that owen patterson was guilty
or not
i think it was a a very sad case but i
think there's
no question that he had
fallen followed the rules on on paid
advocacy as far as i could see from the
report i think the question that uh
people wanted
to
to establish was
whether or not given the
uh
particularly tragic circumstances uh
he'd had
um
the
fair
right to to appeal he had an appeal his
appeal was heard
endlessly and both by the uh by the
committee yes
mr brown and i wish to to restate that
um informing the impression
uh that
um
uh
the former member for north shropshire
had not had a fair process
i may well have been uh mistaken i mean
but that was certainly the impression
that many people seem to have
theresa may said yesterday that your
actions
over this case were misplaced ill-judged
and just plain wrong
well i look i i've i
think i've said
several times now i i do think it was a
mistake
to conflate as as we did
those those two things uh a particularly
uh difficult case uh it's not often in
uh
uh house of commons when a colleague
suffers a family bereavement in the
course of
uh an investigation
there was there was quite a lot of
feeling about it
and
um
for that reason in a spirit of of
compassion
i thought it might be useful to see
whether there was any any any
cross-party support but you didn't
approach cross-party at all did you you
told john whittingdale that there was a
cross-party agreement to set up this
committee but that wasn't the case was
it so it would see
well why did you tell him that
well sorry i i i
can't comment on on that conversation
since i didn't uh have it but um what i
what i can say is that i believed that
there would be
uh
cross-party support for the
idea how did you believe this is just
out of your head you came up with it
it was it was it was put to me that
uh people who
buy
colleagues uh that people would feel and
and indeed i i was
um
fortified in this by the by the
reflection that many people would have
felt that this was a particularly
difficult uh and sad case and many
people across the house uh would have
felt a degree of sympathy uh for uh the
the member for fraption north and and uh
would have thought that the problems
uh that there might have been it might
have been possible
uh to consider whether the
the process uh was capable of of
improvement and i i'm very
and
yeah very willing to accept that i was
mistaken in that in that belief
the problem is
that you say that the country's not
corrupt
but what owen paterson did was a corrupt
practice it was lobbying
um ministers and officials on behalf of
his paying clients it's a corrupt
practice
and the danger is that you've just tied
up but by all of this you've tied the
whole of the house
with the same brush and yourself haven't
you
it was as i said that if you if you
recall what i said mr bryant the prime
minister's questions on that wednesday i
began
by saying uh that paid advocacy uh is uh
and lobbying
is against the rules and anybody who
does that should be uh properly
penalized i that was that was how i
began so the intention genuinely was not
to exonerate anybody uh the intention
was to see whether there was some way in
which on a cross-party basis uh we could
um
uh improve the system now in retrospect
in retrospect it was obviously obviously
mistaken uh to think that we could
conflate the two things and
do i regret that decision yes i
certainly do
mr brown
looking forward prime minister will
accept
the recommendations of the standards
committee that are agreed between the
parties that have the consensus you will
i think it's very the government will
facilitate the implementation of those
changes
which changes whichever changes the
standards committee comes up agreed
between all the parties yes i think what
we're what was what we're saying is that
uh there should be i mean
are you talking about changes to the
standard system
indeed
um
uh of course and i hope that there can
be a cross-party progress on that and i
i further hope that there can be
cross-party progress uh whether in the
standards committee or in some other uh
cross-party body of the house on the the
issues that
i described earlier and i described in
the house
relating to
the conditions and the stipulations
under which
we
we serve and
uh we are able to have uh outside trades
callings professions interests and and
so on uh which is as the independent
committee has said is is of of use to
the house and just following up the
question raised by mr rag
for which i have great sympathy because
the commit his committee under my
chairmanship reached the same conclusion
about the
um
the ability of the independent adviser
to instigate
investigations
i still don't understand the objection
that you have to this which you say
you will almost always accept his
his recommendations to have an
investigation now that
you are
going to be encouraged to uh take
control of the sanctions and mitigate
the sanctions to reflect circumstances
what is the objection
allowing the independent adviser to
instigate his own inquiries i don't
understand it
thank you um so what the uh independent
invite advisor you mean law guide yes
the minister will buy so so what uh lord
guide can
certainly do under the the new
dispensation that we've agreed is that
he can uh suggest to me at his own
initiative under what some circumstances
would want to veto that at his own
initiative and something that he thinks
bears uh investigation or needs to be
corrected uh or where something has gone
wrong
and as i said i think in my my opinion
the answer it's hard to think of of
circumstances in which i would uh i
would want to overrule him
well i can't imagine any either so why
not just give him the power well i i i
think you know
i think the situation i hope the balance
i think i think people can see that the
the balance of the situation is i think
uh
well judged at the moment
yvette cooper home affairs
thank you and uh welcome prime minister
um can i just follow up just clarify
quickly just um the responses you've
just given to um william rag and um
chris bryant um this is an area where we
really need clarity given your important
role and you use a slightly odd form of
words in response to william rag you
said it's a mistake to conflate the sad
and difficult case of a colleague who
has fallen foul of the commissioner on
standards
could you just clarify do you believe
that owen patterson broke the rules yes
yes or no yes and and
uh
at least that's seems to me too
yes i do
and and
uh what we would and
as i said at the beginning of the
pmq's two weeks ago uh we did not
seek to uh in any way minimize the
importance of of that people who uh
break the rules on paid advocacy must
you are still qualifying it you're still
saying well it seems to me do you
recognize that given your responsibility
to uphold the ministerial code to uphold
the rules yes uphold the standards it's
really important that you should not
give any impression that when there is
an independent report that found on 14
occasions of paid lobbying that somehow
you think that's okay can you clarify
that was the first thing i said when i
when i uh when i
uh began on this subject two weeks ago
and frankly i think you know i'd be i
think i think it is extraordinary uh
that colleagues sometimes do uh behave
in this way and
uh and it's quite right that the
commissioner is able to investigate and
and to hold them to account my i think i
was i've always sought to do and i and i
think i've the committee will agree that
i've uh i've
accepted that it was a mistake and that
it was my mistake all we wanted to do
was it was to see whether in view of the
particular and and
frankly tragic circumstances of the case
uh there was any uh scope for
cross-party uh agreement on uh
on an appeals process that was all we
were trying to do
and
given that you have said that you did
ask the business secretary to apologize
the cabinet office secretary has also
apologized would you express your own
regret for not having said three weeks
ago
that owen patterson broke the rules
which would have provided clarity about
the standards that you expect to be
upheld yeah i i began uh
two weeks ago i think it was
by saying
that uh those who broke the rules uh
should uh should pay a price
the issue is whether you should have
said oh three weeks ago yes in
retrospect
yes thank you yes in retrospect it would
have it might have helped a bit if i'd
said
that i believe that owen had broken the
rules as far as i could see
but again you see as far as i could see
you have an independent process that has
looked into this every time you say as
far as i could see well it seems to me
and you try and qualify it you are
undermining an independent system that
we need to work all of us need this to
work we need you to have some integrity
we need you to be able to uphold the
standards yes
then let me repeat uh it was it was
clear to me that he'd broken the rules
he'd fallen foul of the
uh of the rules that we have in in
parliament uh
and i
made clear at the outset of my
statement uh sort of my my first answer
in pmq's uh that
for me that's something that deserves
punishment
my question was uh in all
uh humility given the the particular
circumstances of the case whether there
was any cross-party uh support for
improvement to the system that that was
what we are trying to achieve i know i
can now see that that was
uh a mistake
uh i also think it was a mistake not to
go ahead with the
2018 report of the independent committee
on standards in in public life and i
think we should have i think the house
should have implemented uh those uh
conclusions as well
and do you also accept that the problem
is that with all the prevaricating with
all of the attempting to still be
defensive about the things that actually
everybody accepts that you got wrong
that whether it is
it sounds a lot like prevarication
whether it is uh you know this is a
whole series of things that creates an
impression that is very unfortunate and
is very damaging to public life whether
it is not wearing a mask in a hexam
hospital whether it is the uh initially
defending colleagues who have broken the
rules in a series of different cases do
you accept that you have a
responsibility to be go above and beyond
to go further than everybody should
expect it and to actually establish much
higher standards i do and look uh thank
you um
and uh yes yes i i think it was a it was
a it was a
total uh mistake
not to see that owen's breach of the
rules and the former member for north
shropshire's breach of the rules made
any discussion about anything else
impossible
and and i totally accept that i totally
accept that
and but as for not wearing a mask in
hexham hospital
which you you you wrap up into my
general litany of crime uh can i just
say that actually uh i i was
barely 30 seconds when i wasn't wearing
a mask i walked out of a room mistakenly
not wearing it i then put it on
as soon as i realized i had made that
mistake
i apologize for it but it but most
pictures of my visit to the to the
hospital will show that i was duly
masked uh throughout the remainder of
the visit i was masked on the way in to
the museum thank you for giving me the
opportunity to declare yourself let me
briefly and ask you around the um i'm
not absolutely because it didn't start
till 22 of 3 20. um let me ask you
briefly just around the violence against
women and girls um
less than one percent of actual rapes
are prosecuted less than two percent of
reported rates you've set a target to
get prosecution rates back up to the
2016 levels by the end of the parliament
but you've said that it's going to be
really hard to meet that target even
though it's only 11
so why is that when it is such a
shocking time crime why are we
effectively letting 99 of rapists off
and letting so many victims down
well uh event mr cooper that's an
incredibly
important question and uh it's something
that uh i am campaigning on uh working
uh flat out now in government i lead the
crime and justice task force is our
number one priority you ask why it's so
difficult uh there are many reasons uh
but there are
as you will as you will recall uh
there was a a particular case in 2018
in which
the
evidence from a mobile phone was used by
the
defense
to uh
exonerate uh an alleged perpetrator of
rape and
since then i'm afraid
that there has been a huge reliance on
mobile phone data by uh by defense
council it's a very important point i
understand
what we're doing about it this is the
top priority you've said that it's your
top priority for police forces but you
have refused to put it in the strategic
policing requirement which includes
terrorism child exploitation and
organized crime will you review that
this and now put if it is your top
priority will you put it into the
strategic policing requirement and make
it a requirement for forces across the
country so we're we're making it the top
priority for uh for
for for our police and maggie blythe uh
the deputy chief constable has has taken
over the
lead for it uh we're
insisting that uh mobile phones are
handed back to uh victims within 24
hours is one of the reasons we have such
victim attrition which is that which is
one of the reasons we have such low
prosecution rates because our victims
don't feel confident in the in the
system uh we're going ahead uh with a
under section 28 with allowing victims
to pre-record their evidence to give
them uh more confidence and we're
putting uh a
lot of money into is versus
uh into political domestic violence
advisors
so that they can help victims through
the uh the very difficult period of the
of the trial again to stop this
attrition uh by victims of victims and
uh that the failure to prosecute enough
people we're also investing in uh in
many more prosecutors caroline notes
thank you chair
do you agree that there's a ladder of
offending when it comes to violence
against women and girls and that those
who might perpetrate crimes like
indecent exposure then move on to far
more serious crimes like rape kidnap
murder
i do believe thank you i do believe
there is evidence to to support that and
uh if you look in particular at the
uh the case of wayne uh cousins uh that
was something that uh frankly should
have been uh should have been picked up
and
that is unquestionably going to form
part of the
the investigation into what went wrong
in that case
could there also then be a case to make
crimes like uh public sexual harassment
a specific crime perhaps through the
passage of the pcsc bill which will come
back to the comments soon
um well we have um
thank you very much we have
quite a lot of statute of one kind or
another um against
uh
serious assault sexual violence rape
um
and as as yvette cooper has just been
saying the the the tragedy at the moment
is we're not and harassment
we're not enforcing these enough as it
is
and
i have to think about how uh really to
tackle uh the the crimes that the public
wants tackled rather than widening the
the range of human conduct that
we ask the police to
to criminalize and enforce against what
i want to see is proper enforcement of
the existing
law and as yvette was saying uh pro
prosecution uh much more prosecution for
those who are
accused of rape and at the moment that's
where the numbers are going having
agreed that there's a ladder of
offending should we not have a plan to
intervene earlier before those who are
harassing women become sex offenders
i think that what
we need to do is rather than expand
the
the sphere of
activity that we criminalize we need to
prosecute people more effectively and
more successfully for the things that
are already criminal and there is
abundance of of statute that is not now
being properly enforced and that's where
and that's what we're putting our
investment into
baroness new love has an amendment down
to the pcse bill that would make
misogyny a hate crime do you have any
views on the progress that has been made
in encouraging women to come forward
and the 75 percent of them in
nottinghamshire where the pilots being
carried out who now feel that they have
had a positive outcome and shouldn't we
expand that well
thank you i'll start look i'll study
what baroness new love has come up with
but
and i'm glad that
women have the confidence to to come
forward that's always very very
important but
i
i think the best way for the best way to
tackle misogyny uh and to give women
confidence is to deal with the abundance
of of of
courses of conduct that are already
illegal and that we are not uh doing
enough to tackle that we're not
prosecuting enough in particular rape
and that's why we want to double
prosecutions for the rape but we are now
seeing a small increase
you're right to focus on the efforts
that are going in to increase rate
prosecutions but one of the real
challenges is the way
women don't feel confident to come
forward and report incidents
isn't it fair to say that if public
sexual harassment was a specific crime
that they could point at that the police
could point at and indeed the crown
prosecution service could point out you
actually might see women with more
confidence to come forward i think that
all women should have the confidence to
come forward and
and denounce
the harassment uh
or crime against them that they have
have experienced and there are proper
procedures
for for those claims and those
complaints to be investigated
one of the
cultures underpinning male violence
against women is the easy access to
extreme violent degrading pornography
can we have any confidence that the
online harms legislation that you've
said we're going to get to vote on
before christmas will do anything to
address that we know that people like
wayne cousins access that sort of
pornography should we be doing something
to stop people like him from getting
access to it i think that's an
incredibly important point because i do
think that it is
you look at the evidence of people like
wayne garza not just him but also
i'm afraid terrorist offenders many
others uh are it is clear that people
are are cautioned and uh and degraded by
uh by this stuff and we will see what we
can do it's it the the technological
difficulties are
uh uh are quite uh
extreme but it's up to the uh up to the
online uh giants
to make sure that they don't have this
stuff on their systems and we will take
the steps necessary to to hold them to
account and that is what the online
harms build is designed to to do so we
can have confidence that there will be
legislation
that forces the uh massive online giants
to do that i think it's time the online
giants uh realized that they cannot
simply think of themselves as neutral
pieces of infrastructure they are
publishers and they have responsibility
for what appears on their systems and
the online harms bill is designed to
give effect to
that distinction
if
one final question quickly bernard uh if
there is uh a challenge around
the the culture that underpins male
violence against women should we start
addressing that in schools and should we
look to be making consent classes
compulsory
i i think that
kids nowadays
are
given
much much better
uh and more balanced instruction about
these uh questions than uh was the case
even 10 years ago
never mind 20 30 years ago but there is
a way to go
and
it's certainly something that i'm
willing to look at thank you julian
knight for digital cultural media and
sport committee thank you chair good
afternoon prime minister uh do you think
the acts that are illegal offline should
be illegal when committed online
yeah give an example uh cyber flashing
cyber flashing
i can give you a description if you like
prime minister cyber flashing
um
yes sorry uh
yes i think i think on the whole uh
cyber i don't don't care whether
flashing is cyber or or not uh it's it
should be illegal okay so if that's the
case will you commit to expand what is
at present
the definitions of online harms at the
moment we look at terrorism and child
exploitation
which places a specific duty of care
following on from
uh your answer to my honourable friend
on the social media giants to include
such crimes as
flashing and assisting self-harm pushing
people towards suicide prime minister
on the face crucially on the face of
online harms legislation on the face of
the bill
i thank you mr knight very much for your
suggestion i will make sure that we uh
that we look at it and as colleagues
know the online
arms build is due to leave uh the uh
joint uh
with with respect though prime minister
um
the difficulty we have is there isn't
going to be another online safety bill
in this apartment there may not be one
in another apartment so are you prepared
to shun the opportunity right now to
protect women and girls from such vile
acts such as we described before cyber
flashlight
yes i said the answer to your question
is yes i certainly if we can do
something in the online harms bill uh to
stop cyber flashing which i is is you
know something that is um you know
clearly a a scourge that um is is
developing then then well it's not just
about that it also falls into the whole
violence against women and and girls and
the whole strategy
around this that here's a key piece of
legislative intervention that is going
to become with the house and so far that
scope is so narrow the kimono that goes
on it's just the idea that maybe if you
can if you can draft something uh that
will capture it and uh
you know let's have a look at it and it
sounds it sounds like a useful uh given
there's a five day different time lag
between the reporting of the joint
committee and the promise to
present legislation just to be clear
will we have the second reading as you
promised at the dispatch box
of online arms legislation before
christmas yes or no
i think that depends on the joint
committee i'm afraid to say as far as
right but promise you the dispatch box
it will bring the legislation forward
before christmas if if the joint
committee can conclude its work uh well
they they do with respect privacy
they're actually they are charged with
the
the house conservative doing that five
days earlier so you'll have five days
between the joint committee reporting
and the legislation as you promised the
dispatch about being presented to the
house
will you do that
before christmas yes or no well if if
the joint committee reports
yes
so you'll have five days you'll do it if
they report five days before
we will report as soon as we can after
the joint uh committee has is that
focusing on its work
if it can be done before christmas i
think that would be a great thing as far
as i understand at the joint committee
another due to report before christmas
and after that i don't know what the
delay uh might be uh between uh between
bringing it back and forth another thing
about the prime minister you said at
dispatch box is that uh you wanted to
see the potential criminal sanctions for
social media giants if they fail in
their duty of care that leaves a lot of
wriggle room with the word potential
i'd like to find out for you what you
actually have in mind
will you incorporate a criminal sanction
in the bill in primary legislation
rather than incorporating the potential
at a later date for the secretary of
state to introduce secondary legislation
to thereby introduce criminal sanction
criminal sanctions now
or at the discretion the secretary of
state i i share your
anxiety
mr knight about
the deferred sanctions that we're
currently uh looking at and and uh let
me let me take that away
all right so
is that just a takeaway or if you
actually think that they should be in
place in the bill itself rather than
just me put this
i think that we want the strongest
possible deterrent
and the strongest possible sanctions
against uh
people who run online companies uh who
are allowing a torrent of uh
uh
hateful stuff to appear on there on
their uh on their networks uh just final
question prime minister you said on the
24th of march in liaison committee to me
that you would ensure the eu visas for
creatives and those who are in the
touring industry would be
i don't really quite here would be
sorted you get it sorted
since then the dcms has had a total of
four meetings always spain
not with any other countries
we have the issue of
uh the uh lord frost uh failing to
attend my committee uh for a long period
of time until after point of orders of
the house
so prime minister is four meetings in
eight months
how's that getting it sorted well i'm
i'm very grateful to you and for for the
work that you're
uh that you're doing um i i know that at
least 20 member states including france
and germany now offer uh visa and work
permit
free routes for the touring musicians
and i think i read just uh yesterday or
today
that
uh there had been a
progress made in uh in spain
um
uh so we are continuing to do does that
not show prime minister mayor say that
actually meeting them does actually make
a difference that we should actually go
meet our bilateral partners in order to
negotiate these deals because the issue
is that we are losing
huge sways of the touring industry and
we were the center of touring it's far
bigger than many other industries that
we take a lot more time over so i just
wonder whether or not it would be
actually now time to genuinely face up
to this and to go and have these
bilaterals but at the same time the idea
of uh these other countries we've done
that was a press release that was
released several months ago and frankly
take my word for it
nothing has happened
nothing's happened since march in terms
of progressing until very lately as a
result of those spanish negotiations
okay but i i fully accept your criticism
uh but i what i would say is that
actually the the
circumstances have also been pretty
difficult for uh touring of any kind for
a long time and uh what we what we want
to see is
markets opening up generally for for
touring musicians and for tourists
of all kinds we want to see
many more people coming to
to london
whether they're musicians or not and uh
we should be we should be making an
effort to ensure that happens okay well
we're going to come back to this subject
prime minister it's a subject i feel
very very strongly about and
i think the government could make a more
coordinated effort but can i just go
back to the question of violence against
women
since sarah everard was murdered
about 80 more women have been murdered
nearly all by men and at a time when
women are feeling so vulnerable
what are you going to do to demonstrate
that the government is behind them and
for example will you guarantee the safe
spaces uh for women based on their sex
such as changing rooms hospital wards
prisons and so on
which they feel are under threat
yes so thank you thank you uh sir
bernard um
i i
it's appalling to see uh crimes of
violence against women that's why i said
in my answer to uh to event that it was
our uh our number one uh priority what
we're trying to do is uh all sorts of
measures from uh the uh the stalking
protection order the uh domestic abuse
act uh of the the steps we're trying to
take to to increase prosecutions for for
rape uh were were were doing all that
and
uh i'm not gonna pretend that um
this is uh
making as the progresses uh as
um
that i would like and it's only going as
fast as i would want uh but it is an
absolute priority for the for the
government and you know we're doing
things that make a small a difference
such as putting a lot more money into
into street lights and
making sure that
we have many more female police officers
for instance we have i think 42
of the of the met is now
is now female uh for 43 42 percent of
the recruits are now and are female uh
so we're changing the the culture um
but
we will
we will not rest until women have
confidence in the system confidence in
the streets and confidence that they
will get justice uh when uh they're
attacked and you've been clear in your
message to the joint committee looking
at the online safety bill that you would
like them to look at to include
extreme violent pornography as
harm and online harm and we need to
protect our children from that i do
think that yes thank you i do think i do
so can we move on to uh we're miles
behind of course
uh bob neal
thank you jim good afternoon prime
minister
can i go back to uh conviction levels
for rape cases yes
you're aware of the concern about it
you'd accept of course that there should
only ever be a conviction
if a jury is satisfied beyond reasonable
doubt or unlawfully missable evidence as
to the guilt of the person concerned yes
that being so
doesn't the
success
rate of prosecutions depend upon the
quality of the evidence yes
and therefore the quality of the
investigation yes what more is being
done to invest in investigation of rape
and serious sexual offences both at the
police level training uh and at the
ground prosecution service thank you so
what we're doing is we're we're
investing in uh the uh i think about 85
million more into uh into prosecutors
for the for the uh the
cps
uh
specifically to try to
give them more more heft and to get and
get cases done faster to give victims
more confidence but what we're also
doing i chair the crime and justice task
force and i bring together the uh the
ministers responsible for all of this uh
from uh lord chancellor hope secretary
uh minister for policing uh and crime uh
and uh and so on and uh what needs to
happen
is that the the cps the prosecutors and
the police need to work
absolutely hand in glove from the outset
rather than constantly
passing the butt between each other
about who has failed to assemble the
requisite evidence and and
that's be or who has who's left the file
in the in the wrong condition that's
basically been the one of the one of the
problems so we're tr we're beefing up
the cps but also trying to have much
greater integration and grip by the
police and the cps together
that's a fair observation but also it's
going to require resource to
are you do that isn't
sure that continues to be funded we are
can also make the point that you
referred to disclosure
and the liam allen case
would you accept actually the right to
disclosure of unused prosecution
material which may actually assist the
defendant or may actually undermine the
prosecution's case is a fundamental
safeguard in the system
yes i do of course agree with that
principle but i think what has happened
sadly is that a great deal of data and
information has been mined from mobile
phones and
that has produced um
pain and embarrassment and discomfort
on the part of victims and has
discouraged them uh from continuing uh
with the case
and perhaps even deterred people from
coming forward and uh that's why it's
vital that we delimit uh what the uh uh
the police can use in evidence from a
mobile phone restrict it to what is
actually germane to the case and make
sure the phone is handed back within 24
hours would you accept that that could
be assisted by further investment in
technology for the police and the crown
prosecution service to search digital
material uh effect by uh or ultimate
artificial intelligence in the way that
happens in series four cases will you
put the money into that i i do accept
that uh this is a an area where
technology has moved very fast
evidential uh
uh
demands uh the the the the demands upon
the cps and the people the police
caused by this huge quantity of data
have been very severe
and we need technology artificial
intelligence uh to winner without uh to
to get to the uh to what is
actually necessary for the the
prosecution of the case the other great
cause of victim attrition of course are
delays in bringing cases to court
that requires courtrooms
lawyers and judges
will you be
reviewing the level of funding made
available to the court service
and
to defence lawyers to ensure that you
have good quality lawyers who can handle
these cases in a sensitive fashion on
both sides of the case yes well i have
the
utmost esteem for the for the legal
profession uh and i'm sure that they
they um
will do an excellent uh job but uh what
we what we are doing to invest in um
the
uh
in speeding this up is um
you know we've got to clear we've got to
try to clear backlogs in courts as you
know and so
uh we're
funding uh 32 more
crown nightingale courtrooms until the
end of until the end of march
we've got uh courtrooms to you talk
about technology and you're quite right
we we're equipping courtrooms with cloud
video platforms enabling more than
thirteen thousand cases to be heard
virtually
every week and
uh we are have we've removed the limit
on the numbers of days the crown courts
can sit uh and and so forth we've got a
new super courtroom uh in manchester and
uh we're working flat out to bust the
backlog certainly people are working
flat out and i know the judiciary and
lawyers are but i also aware however
that on number occasions recently
serious cases have been had to be taken
out of the list because lawyers were not
available either to prostitute or defend
them or because judges are not available
and that is because experienced lawyers
are leaving the profession because of
the low levels of pay you have the
chance to put that right with sir
christa pavella his review will you
commit to funding the the the results of
the bellavi review into criminal legal
aid i would certainly study the the the
review into legal aid with uh great care
and create great interest when we
certainly believe that um
the criminal justice system needs proper
funding uh we've provided 150 million
this year for victims of witness witness
support services getting back to the
earlier points i was making and the
spending review uh gives another half
billion
to the criminal justice system to help
recover from the pandemic and one final
thing another cause of delay is the
length of time under which suspects are
released under investigation rather than
being bailed that can last for many
months and even years the policing
minister committed in westminster for
reform of that when are we going to see
legislation to reform our rui and go
back to the previous system where he had
time limits on bail brought forward i'm
certainly very attracted to
setting
benchmarks scorecards
for the whole system and that should
include
in my view that should include
timing that should include deadlines i
think that uh the justice delayed is
just as denied and uh and it also
justice delayed is wildly more expensive
are you i'm aware of that will that be
brought forward i i i
we're discussing it right now thank you
very much chairman of the justice
committee um we're now going to move on
to the outcome of cop 26 and its
implementation and we start with
business energy innovation and skills
committee chair
darren
thank you bernard um prime minister
following cop 26
will our climate change commitments
become firm red lines in a future
forgive me um
uh sorry uh our climate change
commitments will they become firm red
lights yes future trade deals uh they
are
uh commitments that uh we will certainly
uh be
keeping and and we lead the world one of
the reasons we were able to make a i
think
uh
a
big positive impact at cop26 was because
we uh we stick to these commitments and
we've made some different reductions in
in co2 so what we say to our friends and
partners um
is that these these matter uh to us so
when it comes to when it comes to for
instance australia
on the australia trade deal
i asked you on monday and you didn't
answer the question we dropped our
climate change commitments in that trade
deal in order to get it across the line
do you regret that
uh with australia
actually includes a substantive chapter
on climate change which reaffirms the
commitments of both parties to upholding
our obligations under the paris
agreement including limiting global
warming to to 1.5 thank you thank you
and and and and
australia
so my question is
what do you give the department for
leveling up housing in communities the
power to block decisions such as new
coal mines in the uk
these are these are matters that are
already uh for
the relevant planning authority i'm
asking if after cop 26 you'll give new
powers to the department i think i think
that the
uh these are already matters for the
relevant planning authority so nothing
will change and i think that what people
can see
is that this government uh leads the
world in moving away from coal and
actually what you've got at cop26 was a
quite a remarkable and historic event uh
as greenpeace themselves
thank you prime minister the reason i
asked the question because we're moving
we're not blocking a new coal mine in
the uk albeit for the steel industry but
instead of helping the steel industry
move away from coal we're facilitating a
new coal mine and it was cited at cop26
that undermined what we were trying to
deliver at cop26 when there was progress
but not sufficient progress on coal do
you not think our actions undermined our
embassy no i think i know i think on the
con i think what happened was that our
actions uh convinced the world that it
could be done and what we had in the you
know in the united kingdom was an
incredible exemplar of a country that
used to be 80 dependent on coal for our
electricity uh uh 50 years ago is now uh
less than one
percent dependent or one or two percent
dependent on coal and we'll go to zero
and we're going to zero uh carbon in our
whole uh power generation system it's a
quite astonishing thing thank you very
much
people could see that that was the most
that was the most powerful prime
minister of the argument that we were
short on time so i just need to stick to
my questions if that's okay um the next
question is on climate aid um it's been
suggested that in order to meet our
climate aid commitments at cop26 the
foreign office will need to spend on
average 2.3 billion pounds a year which
is an increase of 140 based on previous
figures on climate aid that was not in
the budget from the chancellor recently
when will the chancellor update the
house on our increased climate age
commitments oh well darren mr jones
your figures the ones i have uh in my
head are that we've committed to
um
another 11 point we can commit to 11.6
uh billion pounds of climate aid or aid
to developing countries to to go green
we further said that when uh the uh we
go back to point seven uh which the
chancellor's uh uh budget predicts we
will come we'll
go back to by 24 25 and we'll have a
further
billion pounds uh so that's a 12.6
billion pound commitment
from the uk around the world that's
that's an astonishing sum of money and i
think most people in this country uh
think that they should i think
amazed that uh we're making such a
contribution and we're doing it because
we know it's the right thing to do thank
you maybe we can confirm the figures in
writing afterwards it's been reported
that you're minded to split up the
business energy and industrial strategy
department to give the cop president
alex sharma his own energy and climate
change department when i asked the
business secretary about this yesterday
he disagreed what's happening i i i
we have no such plans
and i think that it's the one of the
great things about cop 26 was that um
we
brought business that's right there's no
plan that answers my question thank you
my last question for you prime minister
is about my committee's inquiry into the
mine workers pension scheme uh we called
for 100 of the profits from that pension
scheme to go to the pensioners instead
of the government pocketing 50 to
surplus as it has done historically
and during the 2019 general election in
mansfield you said i'm quoting here i
want to tell the mansfield chap
categorically that we will make sure
that no mansfield miner or any other
miner signed up to the mine workers
pension scheme is out of pocket we will
make sure that all their cash is fully
protected and returned i've looked into
it and we will ensure that's done but
prime minister you rejected my
committee's proposals to return those
profits to the pensioners i'm not sure
why you said to those voters why you had
looked into it and why you would return
all their cash when since your
government has clearly not done either
did you mislead those voters in 2019 uh
well i i can tell you uh mr
jones that uh i certainly uh didn't wish
to to
uh give those voters any false
impressions you said specifically that
you had looked into it and you would
ensure that it would be done and you
said it was categorical that was the
case it suggests that there was some
thought behind it you hadn't just
mistakenly misled voters no
well i i will have to get back to you on
on the the my quotation in the in the
mansfield chap and and i will i will
write you as soon as i can thank you
thank you prime minister for that um we
will expect that um so moving on to
philip dan chairman of the environment
audit committee thank you mr berman uh
prime minister your opening remarks to
the cop cop26 conference in glasgow you
made clear your own personal commitment
to i think you said irrefutably turning
the tide
and beginning the fight back against
climate change
what changes do you think you need to
make to the structure of government to
be able to deliver
net zero britain
i think that government is uh well
structured to deliver net zero in
in the uk
and uh what we have is a
uh a cop president in uh in alok sharma
who will help to continue to make sure
that uh our climate change objectives at
the glo the world's climate chamber
objectives are delivered and
uh alock is going to work with the
incoming egyptian
uh presidency of cop uh the emiratis uh
who uh will be running uh the network 28
and
uh there's
the the real job of work now is is
global
we have to make sure that everybody
all the 190 plus countries uh stick to
the commitments uh that they made and
make
26 real
so his focus will be on delivering the
global commitments at the moment he
chairs the climate action implementation
committee
which relates entirely to the uk
delivery will he continue to chair that
committee
yes
and when did you last chair the climate
action strategic committee which sits
above it
uh i can't give you the date but it i it
was it was not very long ago
would you mind letting us know when will
you be chairing the next one well uh we
are
driving the whole uh green industrial
revolution uh throughout government and
uh it's something that i set out in the
ten point plannings almost exactly a
year ago
we've been
leading it from
the center but also relying on
departments of state to get on and do it
and i i pay tribute to alot but i also
pay tribute to uh to baze uh to quasi
quantum and and
many other ministers who are running
with this agenda and since we we
produced the ten point plan uh we've
actually
seen uh investment in green technology
in this country of the order of 15
billion pounds and the creation of many
thousands of jobs
i think that is the point prime minister
you've you've set a plan you've set a
strategy and i think there's good
coordination in developing the net zero
strategy across departments at civil
service level
but the challenge is that the base
department only a sixth of its
activities relate to this agenda and
other departments uh at the moment are
being left more or less to their own
devices to deliver and there isn't the
kind of oversight which would allow you
to ensure they are delivering
well that's
not true because well we're behind on
the fourth the fifth and the sixth
carbon budget projections for the coming
yes both
sorry but the oversight is being given
by me because
uh we are
driving the the green industrial
revolution the ten point plan uh so on
the on the on cut on cb6 for instance uh
the only way to do that is to is to put
in the um
cleaner greener uh
forms of heating
and that is something that you know
we're continuing to
push on very hard it will be it will be
tough but it can be it can be done and i
think the lesson of of of clean
technology over the last
20 years or so is that a provided
government gets behind it and shows that
it's committed to it
the price uh will come down price of uh
of evs uh is now falling uh the price of
wind and solar falling very sharply
if the cop president is going to
continue to chair the implementation
committee which i think sounds like a
good idea although it's uk focused it
will be diverting him from his global
role uh which seems uh challenging for
him
would you discuss with him the remit
the composition and the reach of the
committee to make sure that they have
the necessary powers to to deliver
across government because all the
evidence that we've had before our
committee is that there is considerable
lack of joined up activity across
government to deliver this agenda we
have multiple ministers appearing before
us and they regularly say they don't
have responsibility for the subject that
we're talking about
well the whole of government uh is
working
to deliver this agenda and
you can see the uh the efforts in the
results that they're producing because
we are securing record sums of
investment in green technology uh we're
reducing our carbon output and we're
creating many tens of thousands of jobs
my final question prime minister is the
the un secretary general said in his
opening remarks that his intent for the
next year is to establish metrics to
measure uh performance by countries and
meeting their
ndc commitments at cop are you intending
to introduce new metrics and
measurements to be able to measure your
own performance your government's
performance against its commitments
the the measurements are clear for
everybody to see and that they're there
in the in the uh the reductions of co2
that we
achieve
and uh
one of the things that was achieved at
cop 26 was an agreement on the paris
rule book so that everybody has common
metrics and common dates by which they
they judge progress
thank you mr just to follow up his
machinery of government point i'm quite
surprised you're so happy
with the machinery of government which
you
undercove it i seem to remember you were
very frustrated with it
and you didn't feel it worked so what
has changed or are there lessons we've
learned from kobed that we can implement
that will accelerate and give give the
public confidence that we're going to
win
i didn't say i didn't say i was happy uh
suburban i didn't think i said i was
happy i said that uh so far
as i can see right uh departments are
are working they're pretty the beauty of
the ten point plan was it set out pretty
clearly where we need to get to
and and how to get there
and what we're also now producing is ten
a specific road maps for each of the
of the areas so for evs or uh or carbon
capture and storage or whatever we are
producing we are so we're producing for
business
the uh the things that government is
doing
to make each of the 10 great projects
investable and i think that will help
things greatly but kovid demonstrated if
you produce real data engage the public
and set up the machinery to drive the
process
you can achieve miracles isn't that what
we need to do with this post-cop agenda
yes uh and and that's what we're doing
and so
uh we we have a a delivery unit as you
as you will know suburban under emily
lawson
but with many others working to her
that is achieving everybody that is
studying the dayton in real time and
seeing seeing where we're going
thank you um now moving to neil parrish
chairman of environment food and rural
affairs committee good afternoon prime
minister um i want to talk about the
practicalities really we've got you
we've signed up as one of the countries
to reduce methane by 30
um so i mean we've got much of our red
meat industry and sheep is produced on
permanent posture and that permanent
pasture holds a lot of carbon in the
soil so and so that's a good thing so
how do we balance reducing our meat
thing is it take all the sheep and
cattle off the hill off of x more i
don't think you want that so how do we
help farmers to get to this 30 percent
not just by reducing numbers can we
bring in new technologies what can we do
uh to help the farming sector well neil
i'm mr parish i'm told that uh there are
very substantial progress is being made
um with new technology uh to reduce the
methane emissions from uh from livestock
and
um i think we should encourage those i
think you can do it without any way um
jeopardizing the quality of the
of british uh food uh british meat uh
and
uh we should look at some of the some of
the breeding techniques as diet
uh there are there are things that we're
looking at there's a dutch company
that's investing in scotland to produce
feed additives that will also where they
claim will reduce emissions from methane
gas from animals by up to 30 so i think
there's a lot we can do so can you sort
of commit also to help farming with with
that new technology as well yes and
uh i think in in new zealand they've
they've
as you know they use seaweed or they
found that seaweed coming it can be an
important additive
we're looking at all that sort of thing
yeah because the type of grass they
graze the more they either they can
digest the less methane gas basically
they give off so i think there's much we
can do i want to move on now to to uk
finances is funding deforestation we've
looked into this um and many banks in
this country you know bank roll these
big companies in brazil i mean brazil
has cut down you know the equivalent of
the twice the size of devon rainforest
in the last year alone so um can we do
more to strengthen our registration to
stop british financial institutions
funding deforestation yes but that's
what they all agreed uh i think about 40
of them at
uh at cop
um uh barclays aviva
uh loads of them uh
schroeder's i remember a big long list
and
what that means
is that their
account holders their shareholders and
their customers will hold them to
account
if they
continue to finance deforestation
and so that you know
the united the agreement at cop
to
um halton reverse
deforestation for 90 of the world's uh
forests
that's underpinned now by agreement from
financial interest
institutions not to fund it and also
agreement from the
um
some of the big uh
companies are grain companies and others
cargo and so forth uh not to to to to
use product because it comes from
deforested land that's right because
again in brazil the savannah is being
plowed up to grow soya beans so all of
this is actually still coming in so i
think it's very laudable what's going on
at cop but i think prime minister what
we need to do is make sure it does
affect what we buy and that we don't
actually stop our
agricultural production in this country
and import from deforested land i hope
you're determined to make sure we should
happen of course uh mr parrish and but
there's no power greater than the power
of the consumer that is that is what
will make the the difference and people
will in the end uh people will make
choices about the the firms whose food
they buy based on uh where uh it comes
from and huge numbers of large numbers
of companies at cop signed up not to
and that also prime minister needs to be
recognizing our trade deals does it not
well uh i i certainly think that you can
make a lot of progress
on the in these areas on uh on trade
deals and and and all the countries
concerned uh that we're doing trade
deals with as you know uh signed up i
think uh to the uh to the compact on
forest right provided that we're not
importing that food that's from
deforestation and finally just on
plastics i mean we we are you know
plastics are predicted to being a bigger
carbon emitter than coal and i think you
are uh dedicated like i am to actually
reduce the amount of plastic use the
trouble is a lot of the government
efforts at the moment are about tackling
plastic waste and recycling now that may
be laudable but in the end if we could
actually reduce the amount of plastic we
use in the first place i think will be a
much better so what what initiatives do
you see is do you tack some of the
original plastics um when we make the
plastic in the first place um because
you've got to have a method of actually
reducing the amount of plastics we see
being used yes
you're completely right that the
um the answer is not recycling and as
you know we're bringing forward um
measures to stop the export of plastic
waste to developing countries as we said
we would in the
manifesto which i think is right but
you've also got to stop uh the
domestic
needless domestic consumption of uh
production of plastic
stuff uh so uh that's why the you know
with the
charging for bags in supermarkets has
led to a 95 fall in uh
in bag use um uh we're banning i think
you know stirrers and
and so on so we just need to get the
deposit return schemes things going
they've all been delayed so you know can
you give us assurance that you know when
it be where we bottles or what it may be
that we actually get that also up and
running yeah but what we also need to do
is recognize that uh
the best answer is reduce
you know reduce comes before re reuse or
recycle reduce reduce reduce and there
are alternatives to plastics
so we look forward to the new government
i think it's seaweed again i think it's
seaweed maybe maybe one of the key
seaweed scenes with the answer for
everything uh but um it's not just
seaweed there's plenty of other plenty
of alternatives can we move on our
champion
chairman of the international
development
thank you chair and prime minister can i
just take you back to an answer you gave
to an earlier question about
relationship education it should have
been mandatory in all primary schools in
september 2020 but that's not happened
could i ask you to intervene and make
sure it is mandatory because it's the
key to preventing child abuse and
violence against women and girls let me
look into it i i'm afraid i i it's it's
something that uh hasn't really been
brought to my attention before i i will
i will look into it as far as i can
remember hasn't been brought into it
thank you um can i turn to afghanistan
yes i'm sure you'll agree with me it's
looking like hell on earth over there at
the moment you've got the drought you've
got the flooding you've got the
conflicts you've got millions of
displaced people the infrastructure
collapsing and more than half the
country facing starvation over what's
going to be a very harsh winter i really
welcome the fact that we're committing
to putting more aid but i wonder if you
could speak on how you actually see that
being delivered and when you see that
being delivered
well we're we're making sure that we
we've we've doubled 286 million as you
know pounds um we're working as fast as
we can to ensure it gets to to the
people who who need it
you're right the situation is
um
is is grim
um
so
uh we
much of the are
particularly on the healthcare was done
by women and of course if we're
expecting them to step up and deliver
the aid that's putting them in the face
of danger
uh
i i appreciate that point and
um we must make our position clear to
the the taliban authorities that uh
they
you know we we expect them to treat uh
women uh fairly and and equally as as is
obviously expressly
provided for in the quran
and
um
and
we must also engage and we engage with
the taliban this is a slightly
controversial thing but
um i
but strongly of the view when
kabul fell
and
we had the change of regime that there
was no point in the uk just standing on
the sidelines and failing to
to engage with the with the taliban
they may not speak for all afghans far
from it but they are
uh
some kind of authority in kabul if even
if a very imperfect uh authority uh the
uk
must try to engage for the sake of the
people that we are talking about if
we're going to get aid through so that's
why uh we sent uh sir simon gass out uh
who did an outstanding job uh in in
talking to
the talent it doesn't because we
necessarily uh relish the things that
they have said uh or done uh but
we we see practical advantage for the
people of afghanistan thank you and
prime minister uh going back to climate
change how much of the uh 12.6 billion
that you've pledged for climate finance
will actually be spent on loss and
damage
i can't give you the figure now sir but
i i i'll write to you
lassen i think one of the reasons we got
an agreement at cop at 26 was because we
had the chapter on on loss and damage
how much i think i'm
i'm sure the answer is out there but i
will i'll come back to you thank you
very much um i really welcome that
you've signed up to phase out fossil
fuel subsidies so does this mean that
you will now also change your policy on
supporting fossil fuel projects in low
and middle income countries through your
uk export finance organization and the
money that you give to the commonwealth
development corporation
yes we want what we want to do
is
for middle-income countries
and well for every every country that's
having difficulty
moving past coal which is loads and
loads of
participants
the the uk
has
pioneered
with with our american european friends
a new model the country platform
where we set out the
portfolio of projects
that
we want to support but where we want the
the smes the private sector uh
the big banks
uh to come in as well
and these are projects where people can
make a good profit as well as uh helping
to to cut co2 so that's what we're
that's what we're working on excellent
because the problem at the moment is the
exceptions
to that rule are pretty broad so if you
could take to look at the guidance
that's being given to our finance
institutes to try and close that that
would be really appreciated um
i wonder also how you
personally reconcile the new funding to
support the global efforts to tackle
climate change with the severe cuts to
uk
aid programme i'm thinking specifically
the money that we give to bangladesh
which of course is vulnerable to
flooding and sea level rising is seeing
a 62 percent cut in our aid in the next
year ethiopia where the climate change
and conflict blight the lives of
millions will see a 55 reduction in the
uka so is it a situation that you're
doing with one hand but you're taking
away with the other
uh
no because
we are making a massive commitment to
climate finance as as you know which is
which is of
a great value to uh to those those
countries and
uh on oda generally
in spite of the the temporary reduction
to 0.5 because of the pandemic because
of the the exceptional pressures uh that
we face uh we're still spending 10
billion pounds in oda uh this year in in
2021. um that means that we are the
third largest odor donor in uh in the g7
as a percentage of gni we're the only g7
the percentage goes back up as as you
know uh by 24 25 i think most people in
this country uh can see what a huge sum
of money were giving to the world they
think it's right uh but they also accept
that in the grip of a pandemic uh when
we had to spend 407 billion pounds uh to
look after people in this country it was
right to adjust things i i understand
that but i think the problem is that the
immediate pressing issues are not being
funded and yet we're seen to be dangling
money for climate change in the future
so i wonder how you actually reconcile
those two things together in your own
mind
we are we are funding the the as much as
we can of the pressing issues 10 billion
is a lot uh we uh in we're investing uh
more in for instance in uh in girls
education uh and we pledge another 430
billion pounds with a global partnership
for education for a million pounds i
should say uh global partnership for
education over the next uh over the next
five years
thank you prime minister you you have
though 183 million girls education this
year
thank you and please could we not forget
the very important funding for securing
women's rights to control over their
fertility so that we can help support
population control in developing
countries that seems to be a very
important part of it
and education if i may say so sir
bernard is the prior yes but education
without access to contraception is not
worth nearly as much prime minister is
it yes i agree thank you
um
[Music]
we're now going to move on to the uh
budget and spending block of questions
i'm sorry we're going to detain you a
little longer
but we're on good work we're not that
far behind i'm pleased to say despite
everyone going over time um
mel stride treasury select committee
thank you buddha and good afternoon
prime minister absolutely um in march
prime minister you told uh this
committee and i quote i strongly believe
in a low tax government and i am a
low-tax conservative
but i just wondered how you squared that
with the fact that your latest spending
commitments around the budget and the
comprehensive spending review
have led the obr to forecast that the
uk's tax burden will rise to its highest
level since the government of clementi
post-war
but for the very simple reason
mel uh mr stride that uh the country has
been through the biggest fall in output
uh not just since the second world war
but before the
second world war uh the biggest that i
can see for a very very long time and we
had to look after people
uh throughout the pandemic uh we had to
uh spend upwards of 407 billion pounds
on uh schemes to keep uh businesses uh
going to keep uh people uh to put bread
on on on family tables uh to look after
everybody in the country and i think
everybody understood that the problem
should be for the physical impact of
that if i can
i'd certainly accept we had to spend a
great deal of money but a big choice was
made at the time of the budget
particularly with the forecast having
improved from march as to what the
chancellor did with that extra fiscal
space
and he had a number of choices and two
of those were did he spend more or did
he relieve the pressure on tax increases
and the decision seems to be taken that
he would spend an awful lot more in fact
in the budget he trumpeted the fact that
he was spending a greater increase in
public expenditure than any government
this century i think he put it um is
that something you're comfortable with
and how does that square with your
ambition by the end of this part of
getting taxes down well what the
chancellor also did was cut taxes
uh for the low paid
um
very considerably about but
it's burning it's going to rise isn't it
1200 pounds for
a single mum
on uh or single parent on
uh
um
universal credit but prime minister in
the round though that the tax burden is
going to go up very considerably so
we've had huge corporation tax increases
that are freezing of the threshold
these are huge tank broadly based tax
increases that are going on and i'm just
interested in how you think we're going
to get those taxes down given all the
spending that's going on
first of all unemployment is much lower
than forecast people said it would be uh
12
uh it's now uh actually running it at at
levels we saw uh before the pandemic
it's quite an extraordinary thing
unemployment is is a very expensive as
well as a very wasteful and hateful
thing
so uh
we're also seeing faster growth uh than
the many people forecast we have the
fastest growth but the ovals forecast on
growth going forward it's fairly fairly
anemic
we have the fastest growing forecast
for the g7 uh next year
uh so
uh
what i
believe the chance of strategy is and
that's what i certainly support
is to ensure that britain uh the uk
makes takes the steps now
uh to
deal with the
uh the
the debt that we built up to deal with
the the physical impact of of covid but
also to make the
long-term uh
investment we need to drive our
productivity and get growth out of the
economy because just on the looking at
if you want the big economic strategy
for decades this country has
underperformed in productivity
can i just ask on productivity mention
it um prime minister you've urged at
various points that companies should pay
their workers more do you accept that if
wages go up and productive productivity
doesn't and the ovr suggests it won't be
moving very much over the coming years
that just leads to inflation and are you
concerned about inflation and the impact
that that could have on the public
finances
i i think you've always got to
uh watch inflation the numbers
today i think speak to
the
price of energy the
difficulties in global supply chains uh
an economy are coming out of of covid um
but i'd rather have a situation now in
which there was
a big demand
for labor
and an economy recovering strongly
and people wanting
employees then a situation in which
which you and i remember well from
decades ago
both in the 80s and in the 90s of
millions of millions of people unfairly
unnecessarily having their talents
wasted because of unemployment and
that's far crueler and
what we i what i hope is that we can uh
see
uh
investments now leading to
you're quite right at the point that you
make about about wages without
comparable productivity well this is a
critical point but that's why we need to
invest now in the other ingredients that
that drive productivity skills uh
training uh infrastructure and making
sure that we have the people able to
live uh nearer their place that's right
and that that will take time if that
investment is made it's not going to
happen overnight we're not going to see
productivity suddenly spike up in the
next year or two as a consequence of
that and it's not the danger that by
talking up wages as we are at the moment
with inflation so high
knowing that productivity
is
low at the moment and has been since the
financial crisis of 2007 that we're
going to push inflation still further we
could end up in a wage price spiral that
will have devastating consequences on
the public finances so
do you think that maybe the government
needs to be a bit more thoughtful when
it comes to this urging employers to
constantly put up wages without
commensurate increases in productivity i
think yours i may say so i think you're
slightly overrating what the
government's been doing yeah uh the
government has i as it happens i think
that that people should be paid fairly
uh for what they do i think it's right
that the living wage has has gone up but
uh
wages are
and prices are not for the government to
set
they're there for
the market to agree
but they do condition the expectation
amongst the labor market as to where
wages might be going every time the
government says come on everybody's got
to have a pay rise but there's no
productivity improvement to go with that
well i think that
point
whether you i think you're describing
too much
power i think it was the emperor
diocletian you tried that
and it didn't work
well so that's an essay question we'll
know the answer in time welcome pensions
chair stephen tips
i'm on the budget i welcome the
additional funding for universal credit
in the budget but shouldn't some of that
have been directed towards people who
are not
working there's
almost a quarter of people who claim
universal credit are not required to
look for work because of their health
problems or because they're caring for
young children
they all lost the 20 pounds a week
uplift they're facing the big price
rises that we know about
shouldn't some of the help have been
provided for them
uh i i understand completely um mr tims
why you why you you say that
um but just to go back to what i was
saying to mel's stride
what where what we're trying to do now
is encourage people into into work and
so the and and
the situation at the moment is that we
have
uh actually in some places a serious
labor shortage
and therefore the incentive uh should be
to get people into into better paid work
which is why i think the chancellor was
absolutely right
to cut uh the uh the taxes of the to the
taper relief uh on universal credit says
to uh make work pay more uh for those on
uc and now for those who are not in work
on uc
um
i i understand perfectly the point that
that you make and they are people that
we must look after in any event but that
for them uh there are there are other
interventions
that we have such as the 500 million
pounds uh for for local councils uh
the uh the energy uh uh
price caps the the the freezing of
fuel duty uh the winter homes uh the
winter
fuel allowance cold weather payments um
uh and so
support for the cost of child care there
are many many and you and i have talked
many times about uh people
who have no recourse to public funds
even even they have those types of
support do you agree
i think you will but do you agree that
social security should provide an
adequate safety net for families
yes i do but i think the best but the
the best
it's a very important of course i do but
the best thing for those families uh is
to help uh
one member at least of that of that
family into work and that's why i think
what we were doing with universal credit
was right but our committee has heard
from parents for example who will have
to skip meals in order to make sure that
their children don't have to skip meals
because of the 20 pounds a week
um reduction that that shouldn't be
happening should it
shouldn't the social security safety net
avoid that from happening yes it does
but
my point is it doesn't i mean well the
evidence to our committee is that
parents are having to skip meals we're
doing everything we can to support uh
people in those in those circumstances
uh
so
with the five the half billion household
support fund uh the i think it was the
200 million uh holiday uh activity and
food program for her families who are
um
in particular a hardship and i i know
how how hard it can be for some families
but we are
we are putting uh money into supporting
those families
i i think that it's also important to
stress the value of of workers the way
forward yeah the headline rate of
benefit at the moment is the lowest it's
been in real terms for over 30 years
in those 30 years the economy has grown
by more than a half in real terms and
yet support for unemployment families
hasn't gone up at all
in that time that that doesn't seem
right does it
well i'll have to study those figures um
the the welfare budget as as you know
uh because you're a
great authority the welfare budget is is
is still extremely big
yeah well let me just finally quote to
you at the statistic from that house of
commons library that says that if you
compare
on the level of unemployment support
today with average earnings it's less
than it was when lloyd george introduced
unemployment benefit 110 years ago
there's something i think that's that's
going seriously wrong there can i just
uh ask about one different can i just
just repeat that by my point we're in a
situation now where the
uh
there is a massive demand for for for
labor
and
um we want to encourage people uh
through the the benefit system into work
and that's why it's structured in the
way that it is but you want them to
afford meals so
the meal of course of course that's why
we have the the protections that we have
a final point i made about a different
topic in our meeting in july you kindly
undertook to look at the online safety
bill that we've come discussed already
this afternoon given that one of its key
objectives is to tackle online fraud i
know you've had a letter today from from
martin lewis sir richard branson dawn
french and others who've all appeared in
online scam adverts
calling on you as we were talked at the
meeting in july
about regulating online scam advertising
or regulating online advertising in the
online safety bill and have you been
able to make any headway in looking at
that point thank you i i haven't seen
the letter from
the
people that you you mentioned uh were
certainly very concerned about online uh
scams uh or online ads of any kind and
uh i know that we are uh we're looking
into this
again i
refer you to what we're doing in the
online bill
at the moment the bill isn't proposed to
regulate paid for advertising um
you made the point in july you'd have a
look at that
let me let me let me see you see what i
can uh
uh
find out about that uh mr tim's uh as i
understand it at the moment
the view is that the bill can't deal
with every
ill
caused by the internet um
and it may be that that's one thing that
it's one thing it's failing to do
one of many things that it's failing to
do but i will get back to you
thank you mr timpson
um
angus brenda mcneil chair of the trade
committee oh i beg your pardon to pass
outward i do apologize
thank you chair and thank you prime
minister defence we've had two terrorist
attacks uh in the uk this last month
it's now two decades since 9 11
and extremism is now on the rise no
doubt spurred by
events in afghanistan
the internet is now more powerful than
the pulpit
in the mosque
should we be doing more to tackle online
radicalization
i think there's always much more that we
should do to tackle
um radicalization
online
uh or or otherwise and when you look at
some of the cases that we've seen
recently it's clear that people are
increasingly adept at using
um
concealed devices to conceal their
internet uh tracking their internet
history uh
as they radicalize themselves um
we need to
to be wise to that i think what we also
need to do with mr wood is we need to
be much more ruthless in joining the
dots together
because so often uh with characters who
uh cause
the responsible terrorist attacks or
whatever
there will be things in their past uh
that were signals or indicators of a
likelihood that they will they will do
this and each of them each of them
individually
may not be enough
to trigger our concerns can i welcome
back but i'm not so interested in
believing
and whether you think there should be
more responsibility to be taken by
the online organizations and i hope you
would lean into this can i just move on
the last time we
met here you agreed the world's becoming
more unstable more
complex there's an increase in political
warfare along with a rise in extremism
we just discussed and authoritarianism
we now see examples of that
playing out in eastern europe can i ask
what military assistance we can offer
both poland and indeed ukraine to show
russia that we are serious about
deterring any kinetic action
the two cases are
very different as you know uh because uh
poland has a
uh
nato security guarantee
and under article five we're committed
to the to the event to the defense of
poland as as you know uh ukraine uh
sadly for historical reasons does not
have the same uh guarantee from nato
powers actually ukraine doesn't even
have a membership action program as you
know
um and
uh so what we've got to to do
is to
make sure that everybody understands uh
that the the cost of uh miscalculation
uh on on the borders of both ukraine and
independent would be enormous and
i think that
my impression as i'm sure you would
agree having
been to ukraine several times
met people as i'm sure according to have
around this room talk to them i think it
would be a a tragic tragic mistake uh
for uh for the kremlin to to think there
was anything to be gained uh by
the way i put it to you that the only
way that we're going to deter
potentially russia from uh to mass
troops on the border with ukraine from
venturing into the donbass region is by
us
saying now exactly what the consequences
would be i invite that to you to take
that away with you cop 26 has helped
illustrate just how fragile our planet
is but
our turnaround to repair this damage is
measured in decades carbon neutral by
2050.
this means that globally we must now
brace ourselves for profound changes to
our way of life over the next decade
crop failures leading to mass food
shortages lands becoming too hot to live
in all leading to mass migration on
biblical
scales this will test governments across
the world particularly in africa does
the prime minister agree with david
attenborough who said
make no mistake climate change is
the biggest security threat that modern
humans have ever faced
i think he's writing that and uh
actually i made a speech to the un
security council saying substantially
the same thing
thank you bringing those two themes
together the red book here
on page 40 confirms defense spending is
set to fall
over the next four years
the current budget has been stretched
by
the requirement to cover cyber and space
domains at the expense
of the traditional services so tanks
ships planes and troop numbers are all
now being cut
would you agree prime minister that the
integrated eu is arguably out of date
and we now need to look seriously
defense spending
to be increased to three percent
no i i must respectfully i know you're
you're a great uh authority on these
matters mr ellwood but i must
respectfully dissent from you when you
say that uh the integrated review review
is is out of date uh because i i think
what what would be out of date would be
to uh first of all we're spending record
sums on uh on on defense uh 24 billion
pounds uh uh
to reform and renew our our armed forces
uh two point four percent no i i know
the numbers yeah you know i know but i'm
trying to say but what i'm saying to you
is that he's done but i disagree we've
just
the budget is being reduced by 0.4 i
have it here in front of me in the red
book
i'm trying to say is i'm simply inviting
you to recognize the growing threats
that are coming over the horizon and ask
you to please recognize and reconsider
where the integrated view now is and
what we need to prepare for if if you're
saying uh mr elwood that you think we
should um
go back and uh
and prepare for tank battles
in uh you're putting words into my mouth
i i don't know what like what are you
saying that well you mentioned but you
mentioned european we are cutting back
on our tanks what is amassing on the
russian border right now in the
ukrainian border it's tanks
but that's besides the point i'm saying
step back look at the wider security
picture look at our defense posture and
see what needs to be done you think that
uk tanks are the answer no no no no no
you're going down
i'm really sorry you're taking us down
this rabbit hole because you know
perfectly well it's not about electives
are one element of a wide spectrum of
our defense capabilities brought up
tanks mr old tanks you brought up
aircraft 48 aircraft f-35s you promised
138 you've cut back to 48 you cut back
on not just tanks warriors have been
removed completely hercules aircraft
removed completely and then ten thousand
troops have been removed so we can talk
about tanks or we can talk about the
wider spectrum of capabilities that have
been reduced at the very time i'm trying
to make clear that there are bigger
threats coming over the horizon prime
minister and i think what i'm trying to
make clear is i think that uh it's now
or never uh for the uk armed forces uh
we have to recognize that there's never
the old concepts of uh of fighting big
tank battles on uh
in on the european land mass which i i
think is what you're driving at uh uh
are over
and there are other uh better things
that we should be investing in uh in the
f gas in the future combat air system uh
in in cyber uh this is how this is how
warfare in the future is is going to be
be fought in our advanced early warning
systems uh and that is where we need uh
to be i think that the the investments
that we are making you can't play around
with the science
in new technology are absolutely
indispensable to our ability to fight
identities of the tradition
and i don't think that going back to a
1940s style approach will serve us okay
mr mcneil tried committee chair
if you're an advocate as we all know of
brexit uh you're now an advocate of
trade deals which i think will both
agree the circumstances are a good thing
given where we are now your government
figures we'll say that brexit will cost
something like 4.9 percent of gdp the
obr the four percent of gdp and we can
correspond that for ease of
understanding to 490 or 400 pounds the
question i want to ask you is what will
you recoup in the trade deals that you
know an advocate of with new zealand for
instance how much would you recoup
either in percentages or pounds and
australia what would you recoup
uh i think i think that both uh deals
will
give opportunities
uh i can't
give you numbers luckily i'm here
because it depends it depends how much
um
uh the australians in the new zealand
when they decide
the prime minister and the question and
thank you sir
um
what we what we do have is
uh a big opportunity for uh for scottish
beef uh for scottish
um no it's not uh and um
i'm looking for numbers he hasn't got a
number so i want to do that the the the
as the
uk
deal alone
uh could increase exports by about a
hundred million pounds uh that's that's
uh
that will be will be scotch whiskey
is that to be are you
using no no no i'm telling you what your
days are there i'm saying traffic are
you against it snp is against every free
trade
what we're looking for here is the
answer is for four hundred or four of
the ninety percent that brexit costs
there'll be four hundred or four of the
ninety-one brexit costs and australian
trade will take back two pounds and a
new zealand trade deal would take back
one pound so you're still 487 pounds out
of pocket is the deal that you've landed
the british people and that is why you
have the problems you have you're in a
pickle with ireland as well you know
it's probably knows the british problem
in ireland uh ireland
is ireland being independent in nuisance
to your prime minister because
i sometimes wonder you if you wish it
never became independent uh and richer
per capita than the uk are you quite
happy that it has i mean what is your
relationship with ireland at the moment
given the threat of the protocol and
you're triggering of uh 16.
we have terrific relations with with
dublin and and
i think they're
just about our biggest trading partner
fantastic at least he didn't quibble
that they were being been independent
and in the eu and some of the wider
recent years do quibble a bit moving on
um do you think yourselves that keir
stalin should answer davey should stop
sending big value donors to the house of
lords a commonly known as cash for
owners and seen as a very corrupt
practice internationally i think did he
raise that with me earlier on today yes
and i'm looking for another it's
actually my
[Music]
the answer to that is that uh these are
a by and large men of women who have
contributed a huge amount to public life
three million pounds and
uh the the until you didn't want to
continue get rid of the system by which
the trades union barons uh fund uh other
parties uh we have to we have to
go ahead or you have a company
or you have a completely taxpayer
funded system of politics
that we need to continue
with a similar system by which
public-spirited people
give donations but find themselves in
the house of lords this is selling
footages
the people who
the the people you're talking about have
done uh i
think
things that
are acts of great public service uh for
a long time
you see believe in leveling up um when
we level up the electricity market
that's working against many parts of
scotland a green energy that could be
produced in scotland's islands
is cost far more due to the structures
of your government to take green average
energy to the main uk market that divide
from the equivalent distance in the
continental market
it's something if you believe in
leveling up that the transmission and
distribution costs need to be equalized
for fairness and not just that but for
climate uh targets to be caught in a
very serious point in scotland's islands
could the vintage connectors are there
and the right cfd levels were given
could
make it less light actually on european
reducers there is an issue
about the
the cost of transmission
and you're right to raise it uh whether
you get it okay thank you for that last
point i want to raise with you was when
we spoke in this format happily uh 14
months ago i see you recalling you said
i asked you about the who would be
responsible in the uk for empty
supermarket shelves and you said it's
certainly going to be me and the
government do you stand by that still uh
yes i do
you're responsible
for what you mean by responsible well
responsible try to help uh
uh
improve supply chains and that's now
starting to uh to happen but the the
problems the
responsibility of the problem uh is
um
one that's uh caused by a a great many
uh global factors if you're talking
about uh htv drivers there are shortages
of
there are shortages of hd hdv drivers in
in the united states and in china and uh
and across the world uh what we're doing
now is is trying to accelerate the uh
the beginning makes it's made it worse
no i think i think that
it's a pan-european problem and uh what
we want to see is uh
people in this country uh wanting to
become hgb drivers uh because it's a
well-paid uh highly skilled change with
good
good conditions i think some of them i
think sometimes frankly the conditions
have not been uh very attractive uh
least of all for for women thank you sir
well prime minister if you want me to
renew my hgb class one license i'm
standing there yeah well i think i think
jeremy hunt health committee
prime minister there's no one after me
so you can relax and take your time
i've just got two topics uh and i'm sure
we can get through them briefly um
the first one is um about nazanin zagar
iraq her
husband richard as you know just
completed 21 days
of hunger strike and
the iranians have often linked her
detention and that of anushia shari
murad tabas and miran roof
to repayment of a historic debt
can i just confirm with you that as an
independent sovereign country
the decision to repay that debt is our
decision and no other country certainly
not the united states has any kind of
veto
over that decision to repay that debt
well uh jeremy mr hunt you will be
familiar with the complexities of this
sad sad case um from your own time in
the foreign office and um you'll you'll
know how difficult it has been to
forgive me to resolve
but what i can tell you is that we
continue to work with
the iranians but of course with other
partners around the world including the
americans who have similar problems of
of uh of dual nationals in detention in
iran am i happy with the way things are
at the moment no should should we be
able to sort it out immediately that
with the snap of the fingers uh uh by
repaying the ims uh
uh
uh obligations uh yes in an ideal world
that would be uh terrific but as you
know from uh your own experience it's
more complicated than that
i do understand that and i understand
there are sanctions yesterday jeremy
wright former attorney general
said that because the debt predates the
sanctions there is a legitimate argument
that it would be okay
to pay it
but if you can't use a bank to repay it
for for various reasons uh why can't we
do what president obama did in january
2016 and he fly over the crate of cash
to tehran and just repay that debt well
uh it's it's certainly worth
uh worth considering
but as you as as you know these are
these are there are
complexities attached i do understand
and
i think it is also important to
recognize that there are
other dual nationals uh uk dual
nationals uk radio in addition
to nazanin who form a part of the
uh of the equation and we have to be
very sensitive to their needs as well i
absolutely understand that there's one
thing that you could say to all of them
that would give them great comfort which
is that their fate
won't in any way be linked by the uk to
the outcome of the jcpoa talks in vienna
they won't be used as a porn to put
pressure on the the iranians i mean the
last thing i wanted to say is uh nazim
herself
uh is under house arrest effectively but
she can see tv clips
have you got a message
to her about the five and a half years
that it's taken yes and um whether she
can get home for christmas i i want to
say to to nazanin and
she and i have been
in touch as i'm sure she was
in touch with you when you were foreign
secretary
that i'm i'm
horrified i continue to be horrified by
the
the ordeal she's been through i have
nothing with admiration of the way
for the way which she's dealt with it uh
it's been uh
uh unbearable
uh to to witness
and i know how much she wants to to come
home and to see her her family uh and to
see richard uh to see her daughter and
to be able to to come back to this
country i can tell you that we are
working as hard as we can
to ensure that we deliver that it is it
is not easy
and
uh if i could tell nazzani now
uh that we'd have a home
for christmas i certainly wouldn't it
breaks my heart i can't make that
promise
but we will continue to to do what we
can
thank you
second area
from me completely different it's nhs
staffing
and we know that
in a pandemic
we've recruited five and a half thousand
more doctors 10 000 more nurses which is
very welcome
but we also know that there are 93 000
vacancies in the nhs with shortages in
every single
specialty now sir bernard i and five
other select committee chairs have put
down an amendment to the health bill
asking for independent estimates to be
published every couple of years
as to how many doctors and nurses we
should be training
will the government support that
amendment
well i'm
very interested in what you're saying
and i'm very interested in the amendment
but uh
what we have our own targets and
ambitions as government as as you know
we want another 50 000
more nurses and we're on track to
deliver that by the end of the of the
parliament there is now a record number
of uh of health care professionals in
the nhs more than ever
before
we are
working as hard as we can to get more
gps which was raised earlier with me in
the house
and to get more radio radiographers
we're short we're short in many in many
in many key areas um whether
our campaign would be helped uh by the
the measures that uh he you you propose
i i you know i can't say but we're very
happy to study them just to be clear
we're not asking for any new targets
just for independent estimates of the
numbers that we should be training given
that it takes
seven years to train a doctor but could
i just ask you to put yourselves in the
shoes of
a doctor or nurse on the front line so
the royal colleges just to give you the
exact numbers
who are by no means you know political
extremists that you know very reasonable
they have calculated we need 500 more
obstetricians 1400 more anesthetists
more radiologists 2 000 more midwives 2
000 more a e consultants two and a half
thousand more gps and 39 000 nurses
today so
why would you not want to give those
people on the front line
the encouragement that we are at least
if we can't solve the problem right away
we're at least training enough for the
future what
i'm not ruling your idea out jeremy uh
what i'm saying is that we we've set
some pretty ambitious targets already uh
we've we've got record numbers in the
nhs um we'll we'll i will look at your
idea
thank you and last one uh
very very very briefly yes um all that
training is funded by health education
england but even after the spending
review they still haven't been given
their budget
could you promise with all these
desperate staff shortages that it won't
be cut in real terms
i
the
budget
and the um
uh spending review
add another 36
if you if you look at the health and
social care but the bit of it that's on
training has not been settled
another 36 billion
on top of the extra 92 billion that we
put into frontline healthcare on top of
the 33 billion that we put in two years
ago when we uh when we came in uh i i'm
sure that there is within the nhs budget
there must be funds for health education
but i will look at
what you say thank you thank you thank
you thank you very much
you've been generous with your time with
us today and
generous that you've given us the three
sessions this year on top of the delayed
session in january so it's the fourth
time this is the fourth as well right
yes uh but thank you for that and we
will see you next year see you next year
thank you thank you order order
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended